>> Joey: BRAGGADOCIO'S BOD,
TRYING TO MAKE A BIG COMEBACK
EVEN WITH TERRIBLE POLL NUMBERS.
AFTER A WEEK OF RESTING ON THE
BEACH AT DELAWARE, GETTING UP
FOR A VICTORY TOUR OF THE
COUNTRY TO TOUT SOME LEGISLATIVE
WINS IN HIS WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF IS ARTIE OUT THERE WITH
THE TRASH TALK.
>> I DON'T THINK HE IS OUT THERE
LESS THAN ITS PREDECESSORS.
I JUST THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP
CREATED A EXPECTATION OF A
PRESIDENT CREATING A [BLEEP]
STORM EVERY DAY.
AND THAT LED TO A CYCLE OF CABLE
NEWS COVERAGE AND TWITTER AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT MADE
PEOPLE IN YOUR LINE OF WORK VERY
BUSY AND VERY PRODUCTIVE.
>> Joey: THE MEDIA RAMPING UP
THE BIDEN TIME MACHINE,
"NEW YORK TIMES" TRYING TO MAKE
THE PRO BIDEN DARK MEME A THING
WITH THIS QUOTE DARK MIME --
ALSO CLAIMING AVIATOR JOE IS
BACK AT SOME OF THE SHADES ARE
AN EMBLEM OF THE CONTINUED VIGOR
AND CHECK OUT THESE LAPDOGS.
>> IT IS A BIG DEAL.
>> THIS IS HUGE AND I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HOW BIG
THIS IS.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARILY SUCCESSFUL TWO
YEARS LEGISLATIVELY.
>> VICTORY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> SUCH A BIG WIN FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN, FLYING BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
JUST FOR THIS BILL SIGNING.
>> Joey: I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
WOULD KNOW ABOUT THINGS LIKE
USING PROPS TO PRESENT YOURSELF,
TO HAVE A PERSONA, TO CREATE AN
ERROR ABOUT YOU, A RECEPTION
THAT YOU HAVE SHOWN THAT THAT
CAN WORK OUTSIDE OF THE RING,
BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
IS GOING TO MAKE AVIATORS WORK
OUTSIDE THE RING.
>> Tyrus: HERE IS THAT THING
EITHER YOU HAVE THE CHARISMA OR
TARISMA WHERE YOU CAN WEAR A
CART AGAIN AND SOMEDAY SAYS IT
IS A SWEATSHIRT AND YOU STILL
LOOK ALL RIGHT, YOU EITHER HAVE
IT OR YOU DON'T, AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
PROBABLY DON'T.
I DON'T CARE HOW YOU DRESS IT
UP, GLASSES, DARK BRANDON,
WHATEVER, HE IS STILL SHAKING
HANDS WITH GHOSTS AND DOING ALL
KINDS OF STUFF, WHAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THERE IS ENOUGH CHINESE FENNEL
IN THIS COUNTRY, THE STAT WAS
LOOP READING TODAY TO KILL
AMERICANS SEVEN TIMES OVER, THE
BORDER CRISIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
OUR INFLATION, PEOPLE LOOKING
AROUND.
HE HAS SPENT A TOTAL OF FIVE
MONTH SO FAR OUTSIDE OF THE
OFFICE WHICH IS THE MOST OF THE
LAST THREE PRESIDENTS, SO TO SAY
THAT HE IS PRESIDENT AND DOING
THINGS, HE IS STOPPING HIS
VACATION TO COME BACK BECAUSE
THIS IS THE FIRST POSITIVE THING
HE HAS HAD TO WHERE THEY HAVE TO
COME BACK FOR HIM TO DO THE BILL
SIGNING.
IF HE WAS DOING SO WELL HE WOULD
NOT HAVE TO STOP AND BE LIKE
HEY, LOOK WHAT I DID.
CHECK ME OUT, PUT MY GLASSES ON
AND WHAT NOT.
BECAUSE HIS POLL NUMBERS, STILL
POLL NUMBERS THAT HE HAS, THEY
ARE NOT EVEN GOOD, THEY ARE JUST
THE BEST HE CAN HAVE.
THIS ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION, THEY
KNOW AMERICA IS SICK OF IT.
SO THEY ARE TRYING TO ACT LIKE
THEY HAVE ONE THING OUT OF 50.
CONGRATULATIONS, THAT'S STILL
HORRIBLE NUMBERS.
SPEECH >> Joey: YOU KNOW,
KATIE, WHEN HE BROUGHT THE
AVIATORS BACK, AND I'M NOT
SAYING ANYTHING DISPARAGING,
IT'S PRETTY SICK.
BUT HE GAVE THAT SPEECH WHILE HE
WAS SUFFERING FROM COVID AND I
GET IT.
YOU MIGHT LOOK DARK IN THE EYES
WHEN YOU ARE SICK.
BUT MADE A REALLY GOOD
STATEMENT, WE DON'T WEAR A
SUNGLASSES AND OUR BUSINESS
BECAUSE WE NEED TO -- YOU NEED
TO SEE OUR EYES, THAT'S HOW WE
COMMUNICATE.
HE IS PUTTING A WALL BETWEEN HIM
AND THE VIEWERS, MAYBE THAT'S
WHY HE CAN'T TELL WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
>> Katie: JOE BIDEN IS TOLD
DEEPLY UNPOPULAR WHEN IT COMES
TO THE POLL NUMBERS, AND I'M
SURE JUSCO WILL ARGUE THAT THEY
ARE COMING UP IN THE PAST WEEK,
BUT THEY ARE STILL DEEPLY
UNPOPULAR.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS HIT HIM AWAY
BACK AWAY FROM THE PRESS DURING
THE ONE-YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL WHICH WAS
A TOTAL CATASTROPHE.
JOE BIDEN IS RIDING HIS BIKE ON
THE BEACH WHILE DEMOCRATIC
MAYORS ARE PARADING REPUBLICANS
VERSUS SENDING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO SANCTUARY CITIES.
THEY SHOULD BE HAVING PHONE
CALLS WITH JOE BIDEN ABOUT THAT
PROBLEM.
BUT THE BEST PLACE FOR JOE BIDEN
TO BE AS AWAY FROM THE CAMERAS
AND AWAY FROM GIVING ANY KIND OF
STATEMENT, BECAUSE WHEN HE DOES,
HIS PRESS SHOP HAS TO CLEAN IT
UP TAKING HIM LOOK LIKE HE IS
NOT CREDIBLE.
AND IF HE IS GOING TO HAVE A
COMEBACK, YOU THINK YOU WOULD
SEE A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
RUNNING FOR ELECTION OR
REELECTION ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
IN THE SENATE OR THE WHITE HOUSE
INVITING HIM TO COME CAMPAIGN
FOR THEM.
BUT INSTEAD THEY ARE RUNNING AS
FAR AWAY AS POSSIBLE FROM
JOE BIDEN INCLUDING IN OHIO, AND
YOU ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF
DEMOCRATS REFUSING TO SAY
WHETHER HE SHOULD RUN AGAIN IN
2024, INCLUDING
SENATOR WHITEHOUSE JUST TODAY.
SO JOB BIDEN'S POLL NUMBERS GO
UP WHEN HE IS AWAY FROM THE
MEDIA, BUT IN TERMS OF SUCCESSES
AND ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND
BEING TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON, THEY ARE HAPPY TO KEEP
THEM AWAY FROM REPORTERS.
>> Joey: YOU KNOW, JUDGE, I
GUESS THE MEDIA IS WORKING
REALLY HARD TO MAKE JOE BIDEN
LOOK LIKE HE IS HAVING SUCH A
LEGISLATIVE WINDFALL RIGHT NOW.
DOES THE CHIP ACT AND THE NEW
NEW GREEN DEAL WITH MAKE UP OR
WHAT HAPPEN IN AFGHANISTAN A
YEAR AGO?
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT THE BORDER?
I GET THAT MAY BE DEMOCRATS
DON'T THINK TRUMP HAD TAX CUTS
AS A VICTORY, I DON'T THINK
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS SEE
THIS AS A LEGISLATIVE WIN THAT
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY ARE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T KNOW
ANY AMERICAN WHO IS RUNNING
AROUND SAYING THANK GOD
JOE BIDEN GOT THESE LEGISLATIVE
WINS.
FIRST OF ALL, LEGISLATIVE WINS
THAT THEY TALK ABOUT LIKE THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS ALIVE.
THE CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE
AT --
>> Joey: THEY ARE NOT CALLING
THAT ANYMORE.
WE ARE CALLING A DEGREE NEW DEAL
NOW.
SPEW ON BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT IS
WHAT IT IS BILLED AS.
THAT'S HOW THEY PASSED THE BILL.
THEY LIED TO US IN ALL OF
AMERICA KNOWS THAT THERE WAS A
LIE.
AND THE TRUTH IS THAT THIS
PRESIDENT AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PURSUE
THEIR OWN AGENDA AND NOT THE
AGENDA OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND TYRUS IS RIGHT.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN 150,
150 VACATION DAYS, THAT IS FIVE
MONTHS OFF IN A YEAR AND SIX OR
SEVEN MONTHS.
THAT IS CRAZY.
HE IS NOT CAPABLE.
AND COMPLAINING AND SAYING THAT
DONALD TRUMP CAN -- EVERY DAY
THERE WAS AN F STORM THAT
DONALD TRUMP CAME OUT.
YEAH, THERE WAS, YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE HE WAS DOING THINGS IN
THE LEFT WAS GOING CRAZY,
BECAUSE THEY OBJECTED TO IT.
AND IN THE END, WHAT YOU HAVE
GOT ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING
CRAZY EVERY TIME DONALD TRUMP
DID SOMETHING.
AND THE DEMOCRATS AT THIS POINT
ARE SAYING, WE HAVE TO BUILD JOE
UP, EVEN THOUGH HALF OF US DON'T
WANT HIM TO RUN AGAIN, EVEN
THOUGH MOST OF US DON'T THINK
THE GUY IS CAPABLE OF FINISHING
A THOUGHT OR SENTENCE, BECAUSE
IT IS IMPORTANT TO US SO THAT WE
CAN WIN.
>> Joey: JESSICA, IT'S GO
POINT, HE HAS BEEN ON VACATION,
GOT ELECTED FROM THE BASEMENT.
MAYBE HE CAN GET REELECTED ON
VACATION.
MAYBE THERE IS A STRATEGY THERE.
BUT IS THIS BIDEN'S WIN OR
BIDEN'S VICTORY?
OR IS IT CHUCK SCHUMER'S
VICTORY?
SPEW OUT THE LINK ASKED ME TO
ITS DEMOCRATS VICTORY, THAT'S A
DECISION THAT PEOPLE MAKE, KATIE
IS NOT WRONG, HE HAS BEEN
PORTING ON A POPULARITY, BUT THE
DEMOCRATS OF THE PARTY AND THE
CHOICE OF AMERICANS HEADING INTO
THE MIDTERM ARE GETTING
INCREASINGLY POPULAR NOW TIED IN
TERMS OF WHO IS FAVORED TO WIN
TO BE IN CHARGE OF CONGRESS, AND
FAVORED TO WIN BACK THE SENATE,
MITCH McCONNELL WAS CAUGHT
YESTERDAY AND ASKED ABOUT WHAT
HE THOUGHT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
AND SAID THAT THEY ARE NOT
LIKELY TO TAKE BACK THE SENATE.
A FEW MONTHS AGO,
MITCH McCONNELL FELT PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT THOSE ODDS.
IN TERMS OF WHO IS ACTUALLY
HAPPY, THIS EXAMPLE, DIABETIC.
PEOPLE WHO NEED INSULIN FOR
EXAMPLE.
WHIT KLEIBER SHARED A STORY
ABOUT HIS NOW PASSED WIFE EMILY
WHO TOOK INSULIN AND PAY $1200 A
MONTH FOR HER DOSES.
IT IS DOWN TO $35 A MONTH
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT NOW
MEDICARE CAN NEGOTIATE DRUG
PRICES.
NOW THE INFLATION REDUCTION --
>> Joey: DO YOU THINK THAT
300 BILLION WILL GO TO JUST
THAT?
>> Jessica: I KNOW THAT SENIOR
CITIZENS IN THIS COUNTRY --
>> Joey: WAS SHOOT WE BE OKAY
TO SPEND THAT MUCH MONEY TO GET
ONE THING?
>> Jessica: IT IS NOT ONE
THING THAT IS GOOD.
>> Tyrus: I HAVE A DIABETIC AT
HOME AND I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY OF
THIS.
>> Jessica: IT JUST GOT SIGNED
LAST WEEK.
I AM JUST SAYING, IT IS UNFAIR
TO REDUCE THE THING THAT IS
UNEQUIVOCALLY A GOOD THING TO
SAY IT IS ONE GOOD THING.
THEY'RE A BUNCH OF GOOD THINGS.
JUST BECAUSE IT IS NOT YOUR
POLITICS DOES NOT MEAN THAT IT
DOES NOT COUNT.
IT IS NOT GREEN ENERGY, IT IS
ABOUT SAVING PEOPLE'S LIVES.
IT'S MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
HEALTH CARE.
YES, HEALTH CARE SAVES PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
WHEN HISTORY LOOKS BACK THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF BIDEN'S TERM
THEY WILL SEE THE RESCUE ACT AND
A BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
TAX ACT, THEY INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT, THEY WILL SEE
THAT ZAWAHIRI IS DEAD.
THEY WILL SEE RECORD JOBS
NUMBERS, LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT THEY
WILL THINK JOE BIDEN WAS GOD'S
GIFT TO THE PRESIDENCY, BUT DO
NOT TO REDUCE WHAT HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED IN THIS TERM, AND
DEMOCRATS GOT THAT DONE WITH THE
SLIMMEST OF MAJORITIES.